[Music]
for their starter prasada making chat at
the licious take on a traditional
gujarati street food [ __ ] small 22
seat Indian restaurant in Bradford has
been at the heart of the local community
for 18 years over time they've
transformed humble vegetarian dishes
from Gujarat in Northwest India into
something truly magical when I'm making
any food I'm so happy I put my positive
thinking and my love so I'm making not
for the business I'm making like my
family chance the Poplar Street dish but
it isn't easy to prepare this recipe has
layer upon layer of wonderful flavors
look simple and sound simple but a lot
of going on three sauces boiling
potatoes boiling chicopee's flying
pasties making chili sauce making
noodles we making our own samosas it's
complicated
first me now prepares a rich tamarind
sauce by boiling tamarind dates and
jaggery and unrefined cane sugar sour is
a tamarind and sweet we were going to
put some dates so right balance sweet
and sour next Kelsey slices samosa
pastry leaves into squares and deep
fries brown color very crispy for the
noodles manal blends gram flour with
sunflower oil it's like soft food if
it's not smooth Dennis noodle be funky
meanwhile counties on to the next source
blending garlic chilli powder salt and
lemon juice yeah
like very hot things extra hot
then the samosas first they find peas
and add turmeric coriander and garam
masala a special blend of spices garam
masala is my own garam masala i roast it
and then I grind it myself
that's right though everything so tasty
finally potatoes are boiled diced and
turned into the mix the last process is
a delicate one filling the samosa pastry
if something goes wrong it's difficult
someone say user you know is a very
clicky ready Jimmy the balance of
flavors and textures in this dish of
pitch-perfect sweet sour spicy crunchy
and soft the way that Prasad bring
vegetarian food to life is a revelation
I am conduct listen really Prasad five
comes away Table one yes thank you mommy
leaving that five have gone I need six
now please thank you yes in contrast the
kazamia boys Mennella and Kelsey are
showing fantastic team work from the
word go mom yes all right yes fine how
are your fine
you're doing those other to please me
now yeah yeah good okay good thank you
Milan and Kelsey are really hitting
their stride their organization is spot
on but they need to watch their
presentation every time yeah I can't
wipe your plate
I cannot wipe your place yeah okay go
please that's table - Bobby is integral
to the success of Rashard Pitts service
throughout the competition has been
charismatic professional and
knowledgeable yeah we try to traditional
Street this show basically bit hot with
the cold the sweet with the spicy just
to kind of ignite all your flavors all
the way through the mail he's also
playing his part in the kitchen
encouraging me now and giving a customer
feedback meal yeah table number three
compliments to the chef
the starters are amazing thank you keep
coming thank you